i don't really like female sports
reporters and analysts in football i
believe there's been an effort to
feminize traditionally masculine spaces
like football i prefer for men to have
those roles that was my stated opinion
as it turns out some people found it
very upsetting the female sports
reporters of the nation rushed to the
scene to try and get their dunks in they
you know they all let me know that my
vicious misogyny will not prevent them
from continuing to courageously report
on sports as a fan of the sport having
conversations with other fans throughout
my life whenever this subject has come
up i have found that almost everyone
i've ever talked to feels this way to
some extent they're not big fans of the
token female
they don't really want females in the
booth as analysts play by play and so on
i've never been around any group where
if i said exactly what i said on the
show they would have stared back at me
wide-eyed and said what how dare you i
have never in my life ever gotten any
reaction like that